[Music]
it was a tearful exit Rebecca Martinez
on Monday night's The Bachelor
Becca tonight we witnessed perhaps the
most shocking elimination in bachelor
history my wife was devastated how are
you doing you know I'm hanging in there
hanging in there that's shocking for me
as well following Becca m's
heartbreaking elimination the 22-year
old nanny appeared on Jimmy Kimmel Live
where she finally got to the bottom of
why she was on the missing persons list
first of all a lot of people thought I
lied to my mother saying that I was on a
farm when I was actually on The Bachelor
but no I had already been eliminated
from the show uh-huh and I just decided
to go up to the mountains with some
friends for a couple weeks and I was
there for six or seven days without
phone service which I thought I was
going to have phone service and I told
my mother that I would and you know I
just had this weird feeling on like the
sixth or seventh day I was like I need
to go home now so I got in my car drove
to where I had service called my parents
and then yeah come to find out only 12
hours before my mother had called the
Humboldt Sheriff's Department saying
that I was missing according to police
reports she was working on a marijuana
farm Becca clarified why that wasn't
completely true saying her friends just
owned a weed farm
[Music]